on weekends [ __ ] hi cops classmates go
out on the soccer pitch or to parties
but [ __ ] heads for the windmill
alongside school the 16 year old is
learning to be a Miller his apprentice -
Hank demos in the one hundred and thirty
year old mill in Dunham's close to the
belgian border couldn't already knows
the routine first he puts out the flag
meaningful Miller is there then the
rotor shaft has to be lubricated with
pork fat according to a centuries-old
practice and finally the sails are
stretched over the rotor blades my
friends like what I do here but they
don't really understand it when I talk
about it they get bored pretty quickly
boring or not windmills are the emblem
of the Netherlands there are around a
thousand in the country and nearly all
of them are still running and not just
for tourists they are still used to
grind grain power sawmills or pump water
into the low-lying reclaimed areas
called polders but there's a distinct
need for a new generation like [ __ ] says
the master Miller he is almost 70 how
days it's mainly retired people who do
it as a hobby
the mills can still be kept in operation
but in 10 15 or 20 years we will have a
real problem part of the problem is that
many Dutch people view the windmills as
props
their flour comes from the supermarket I
had no idea this is more convenient but
maybe a tastes better from the mill for
Leah and lacA Beth there's no question
whether it's rye wheat or spelt flour
his mill in the town of oyster Vic
supplies the bakeries in the area
I'll do when I was molded out of the
watersnake when the old mill stones sing
as the saying goes and when the flower
feels soft and slightly sandy then we
know the quality is good of course
tourists can also stop by to watch and
listen to the traditional craft these
people have come specially from Spain we
come here because it's really popular
that Poland is full of wood the
windmills themselves are likely to last
but whether they will keep providing
Baker's with flour and where the young
Dutch people like geun-hye cop will be
memorizing the blueprints of mills in
the future that is increasingly unclear